Evet efendim yeni bir dünya bir şeyler
oluyor sistemimiz değişiyor Dünyamız
değişiyor bundan zaten Aristo'dan
şikayet etmiş yani böyle bir dünyada
yaşıyoruz bir 3-4 gün sana herhalde
insanlar ya bu gençler ne tuhaf Dünya
nereye gidiyor ne oluyor falan hep
konuşmuşlar ama şimdi Teşekkür ederim
İçinde bulunduğumuz dünya Biraz değişik
bir dünya Daha da değişiyor işte bir
sanayi devriminden sonra çok fazla şeyin
çok büyük bir hızla değişti bir zaman
yaşıyoruz zaman dilinden geçiyoruz Şimdi
yavaş yavaş etkilerini hissetmeye
başladığımız bir şeyler var Mesaj çok
fazla seçeneğimiz var Bunlar arasında
seçim yapmadan kalıyoruz çokluk içinde
genellikle yokluk çekiyoruz Eskiden
yokluklar döneminde yaratıyordu
atalarımız ama şimdi bu çokluk
istiyorsan ne yapacağımızı bilemiyoruz
anormal teknolojimiz var şu anda bir
o çocuklara rağmen birçok insanı
teknoloji ile uğraşıyoruz ama bizi
yalnızlaştıran bir şeye dönüşüyor bu
teknoloji güvenlik için bir sürü
teknolojimiz aracımız var Paranoyak hale
gelmeye başladı çocuklarımızı Sokağı
sağlamaz olduk malum at dolu arasında
doğrusunu seçemiyoruz bilgi o kadar
fazla haber alma hızımız inanılmaz yani
dakikalar içinde haber almazsa kendinizi
bir tuhaf hissediyorum garip bir
haldeyiz Ama en çok kandırıldığımız
çağda bu Çağ oluyor dikkat edin haberle
Manipüle ediyoruz ve hayatımız Maalesef
çok kötü yazıyor gidebiliyor hız çok
büyük bir hız içinde izlese de nereye
gidiyoruz ya bu hız niye lazım bunu Köse
sormuyor Yani devamlı bir hız halindeyiz
E bunun yanında kaybettiğimiz çok önemli
şeyler var ya Bu gidişat içerisinde
gerçeğin ne olduğunu çoğunuz bilmiyoruz
hepimiz uzmanların ağzına bakıyoruz ne
yapacağız Ne yiyeceğiz ne içeceğiz lan
Nasıl yaşayacağız a kadar gerçekleri
anlama da yolumuzu bulmada sıkıntı
çekiyoruz tatlı
bu hayatımızda yani bu kadar çok
seçeneğimiz varken tatminsiz bir şey
yaşıyoruz herkes mutlu bağırıyor Bana
sürekli sonuçlar mutluluk ne diye sanki
ben Mutluluğu bile biliyormuşum gibi
kimsede tarifini yap ama devamlı bunu
arıyoruz hayatında mutlu olmaya çalışır
ve daha iyi bir dünya mümkün mü
İçimizden bir şeydi yok Evet mümkün ama
bunun nasıl olacağına dair hiçbir
fikrimiz yok Şimdi bir de hiç
beklemediğiniz bir o bir Hadise ile
karşı karşıyayız bütün planlarımızı
darmadağın eden bir şey yaşıyoruz iyice
Şaşal aldık iyice ne yapacağımızı
bilemez halde yız ve bence bundan çıkış
için yandı şartların değişmesi Efendim
virüsü aşısının bulunması falan filan
gibi işleri beklemeyi En azından bu 15
dakikada bir kenara bırakalım Benim
başka bir önerim var biraz onu
paylaşmaya çalışacağım Biz aslında diğer
canlılarla birlikte önemli bir özellik
paylaşıyoruz bu artık duymaktan gına
getirmiş olabilirsiniz
bu kuralarını diye bir şey Konfor
alandan çıkalım falan ama bu Konfor
alanı dediğimiz meseleyi Biz genellikle
galiba hep böyle rahatlığı olmak rahata
oturmak anlamında anlıyorsan peki öyle
bir şey değil mesela şu anda oturduğunuz
yere bir bakın Herkes evinde istediğim
bir koltukta oturuyor genellikle o
koltukta oturduğuna dikkat etsin
İnsanlar genellikle başka bir yere
tercih etmeden kendi evlerinde olsa bile
okula gittiğimizde bir sıraya tesadüfen
oturuyorlar bütün eğitim hayatınızı
sırada bitiyor bir toplantı salonuna
giriyorsunuz baltaya katıyorsunuz üç ay
sonra aynı solda girerseniz yüzde seksen
500 gene aynı koltuğa oturacaksınız
başka bir koltuğu istemeyeceksiniz Niye
acaba beynimizin şöyle bir sistemi var
Daha önce bir şey yaşadıysanız orayı
işaret diyor Diyor ki bir daha oraya
gittiğinizde buraya otur burada dur
böyle yap çünkü geçen sefer böyle yaptık
ve Ölmedik hayatta kalma donanım olan
Beynimiz ölmediğimiz yeri işaretliyor ve
bize Şu rahatlığı sağlayan biz oraya
girer
bu devam edelim kafamızı beynimizi Daha
doğrusu bilincimizi gerçek sorunlar için
serbest bırakalım bir daha yeni oturacak
alternatif alanlar aramayalım diye ama
bu alışkanlık koltuğa oturmak açısından
iyi olabilir bize zaman kazandırır
olabilir fakat işimiz ilişkilerimiz
günlük rutinlerimiz hayatı yaşayış
biçimi miz yaptıklarımız bir türlü
yapamadıklarımız' hiç yapmayı tercih
etmedikleri miz hepsi aslında ki
beynimizde bu Abi bu iyi böyle bir tane
böyle görmemiştik gözünü seveyim böyle
devam et bizi riske sokma şeklindeki
devreden kaynaklanıyor Aslında ve biraz
önce gördüğümüz arkadaşlarımız çok
enteresan şeyler dedik burada hepsi bir
şekilde arıza çıkarıp bu Konfor
devresini bozmuş olan insanlardan
oluşuyor Nereden geliyor bu Konfor alanı
bu devreye neye ihtiyacımız var bütün
sürü canlılarında toplu halde yaşayan
bütün canlılarda var ve da ise insanda
bir primat olarak bizdede bu devre var
topluluğa uyuyalım çok fazla
o günlerin beraber güzel güzel yaşayalım
diye ama kargosa uygun bir söz var
hatırlatayım hayvan toplulukları
kalabalıklaştıkça akıllanırsın etkileşir
insan toplulukları kalabalıklaştıkça
söylesem o kelimeyi bilmiyorum ama
aptallaşıyor Uz maalesef ve bu
aptallığın sonuçlarını Maalesef çok
fazla görebiliyoruz bireysel olarak çok
zeki olabilir vesaire ama milyonlarca
insan bir araya geldiğinde mesela hiçbir
canlının 15 milyon Ferdi bir şekilde
oturup da böyle hayatı kendine dar
etmiyor ama biz onu yapıyoruz ve
Dünya'yı aşırı kirletiyoruz kendi yaşam
alanlarımızı berbat edecek kadar garip
davranışlar sergileyebilir yoruz bizim
Konfor Devrem izin bize zararı var Bir
soru daha sorayım temelde bunun zararı
var da biyolojik bir varlık olarak
insanın bu dünyaya Ne Faydası Var bir
düşünelim size de sorayım var mı sana da
faydası büyük bu akıllıca bir şey
gidiyoruz Herkes bir düşünsün şu fayda
Fayda
yok ama biyolojik organizmalar Tabii
Yeniçağ işte bir şekilde ortamı
değiştiren bir organizma olarak yok
Aferim iyisi biyolojik olarak insan
ancak bu dünyaya zararı olabiliyor Çünkü
diğer hayvanlar gibi yiyip içip falan
yaşamakla yetinmiyor ortam Bir de canlı
okuyor duysa insan nasıl da biyolojik
olarak bahsedeceğiz çok bir faydası yok
ama bir faydası var o fayda da zararını
fark ettiği an başlıyor Yani insan eğer
kendisinin farkında olup da verdiği
zararı görebilirse o zaman bunu sanatla
vesaire ile bir üretimle bir yaratım da
fayda ya dönüştürebiliyor bu zamanı bu
ana kadar sabahtan beri izlediğimiz
konuşmacıların Aslında yaptıkları iş
biraz da böyle bir farkındalıkla Ben
daha ne artık koyabilirim yönünde
Aslında yapmaya çalıştıkları işler gibi
gözüküyor hocam bir izole edildiği mizde
evlerde biliyorsunuz bir fayda sağladık
hani ya Kendi fark edecek ya kapatılacak
evi bir çok enteresan Ağa
ya hani nesli tükenmiş canlılar falan
böyle türemeye başladılar dünyada
mutlaka okumuşsunuz ortam bir nefes aldı
Yani biz birşey çekilir ama İşin garibi
tabiat nefes alınca bizde nasıl Onun
için daha rahat nefes aldığımızda fark
ettik Yani Günlük hayır huylarımız
rutinlerimiz içerisinde boğuluyormuş Uz
Şimdi bunu alırken bu hayırlı açılardan
bakılırsa Aslında böyle felaket gözüken
şeylerin güzel tarafları da var demek
mümkün Şimdi benim Konfor devresi bütün
canlılarda var dedim İnsanlar bazen bunu
nasıl başlıyorlar diyoruz Ben sordu
bunun çok basit bir cevabı var başka
canlı da olmayan bir özelliğimiz var
bunun adı cesaret Bu bir yetenek cesaret
dediğimiz yatarak korkarak bile bile
risk olduğunu bilerek adım atmak ve
meselenin üstüne gitmek bir amaca matuf
olarak yani bir şeyi değiştirmek için
cesaret edip para gezmek Ee tabi cesaret
diğer canlılarda bu şekilde Yok ya onlar
korkudan senin üstüne çok fazla
gitmezler işin ucunda çok böyle büyük
açlığa karşı bir yem gibi ödül yoksa pek
yapmazlar bunu ama
bu Neticede cesaret Biz de tuhaf şeyler
yaptırabiliyor Yani insanlar yapabilir
miyim acaba diye düşünmeden
atlayabiliyor bir canlıya bir özellik
verilmişse kısa cesaret gibi bunu
kullanmadığı zaman birşey olması lazım
Çünkü evrimsel olarak bu dünyadaki genel
ilişkiler açısından düşündüğümüzde
hiçbir Duygu ya da hiç bir yetenek
boşuna değil Peki biz cesaret etmezsek
ne olur cesareti kullanmazsak ne olur
burce Süt düşer Sevgili dostlar Esaret
dediğimiz bir meselenin altına gireriz
maalesef net Esaret ne bizi Eser Sokak
aklınıza gelecek herşeyi
alışkanlıklarımız rutinlerimiz
bağımlılık larımız böyle günlük
uğraştığımız gündemler endişelerimiz
ölüm Korkumuz güvende olma isteğimiz ne
varsa devamlı Devamlı devamlı bizi
Konfor alanında durmaya zorlar ve bir
süre zorla onun kölesi haline geliriz
bu cawwot ten önce çoğumuza de tam büyük
bir eser zincir içindeymişiz komik
vurunca farkettik ki dün yapamadığımız
şeyleri yapmak zorunda kaldık ya da hiç
yapmam diyeceğimiz şeyleri mecburen
hayatımızın merkezine koyduk bunlarsız
yapamam diyeceğimiz şeyleri yapamaz
otluk Mesela bugün işte burada
öğrenirsem şekilde toplanıyoruz Fakat
bunlar bize yepyeni bir takım
olanaklarında kapısını açtı the al
üstünden yapar mıydı böyle birşey kurt
olmasaydı zannetmiyorum Ben uzaktan
eğitimde üniversitede yırtıldım
yırtıldım şimdi mecbur oldu bak o
zamanlar Peki ya bu verimli olmaz falan
filan diyordu ama bir şekilde denemek
zorunda kaldı Ama sorun Eğer komik
gelmeden önce biz bunları yapsaydık
bunları deme seydik daha farklı
alternatifler dedik böyle hazırlıksız
yakalanmayacak yani Cesaret edip
harekete geçtiğinde böyle değişimlere
böyle katik hadiselere daha hazırlıklı
yakalıyorsunuz ve daha hazırlıklı
karşılaşıyorsunuz bu
da gelecek aslında şu anda İçinde
bulunduğumuz zaman yeni dünya diye
söylemeyi hep seviyoruz bunu bir sorun
taşıyor bireysel olarak hepimiz için
artık çok büyük sistemler var dijital
destekli büyük karar veren bizim
verilerimizi işleyen sistemler var tabii
bunların arkasında insanlar var ama bu
sistemler artık insanların kararları ve
bilgilerini aşacak kadar deneyimli ve
bilgi hale geldiler biz bunların
karşısında küçük insanlar olarak
maalesef kendimizi biraz Çaresiz
hissedebiliyoruz Ben bugün büyük
sistemlerin karşındaki küçük insanın
zıttı onun antitez olan yeni dünyanın
Cesur insanın ne demektir Nasıl
özellikler içerir Bu sayede çok kısa
onları bir paylaşayım Yani aslında geç 8
maddeyi indir gelebildim Özellikle de
siz deyince Ne anlatacaksın Ondan sonra
bir Ben bunu bir özetleyeyim dedim
İnşallah bir sonraki kitabımızda başlığı
olacak diye düşünüyorum yeni dünya içine
girmekte olduğumuz dünya
o cesaret konuştuk insan hepimizin
olduğu ortak şemsiyenin adı bir
bu durabilmek çok önemli bu devirde her
şeyin bizi koşturduğu sosyal medyanın
Hababam dikkatimizi Arzu ettiği çekmeye
çalıştı heryerden haberlerin heryerden
birtakım Yönlendirmeleri yağdı bir
zamanda durabilmek devrimci Eylem geri
dünyanın Cesur insanın en önemli vasfı
durabilmek önce bir durmak önce kendine
sonra yakın çevresine Ondan sonra daha
uzak perimetre daha uzak çevreye bakmak
yeni dünyanın Cesur insan olmak için
bence iyi bir başlangıç ikincisi
maalesef modern Çağın çok bizim
hayretimi öldürdü Hayret sanatın
felsefenin düşüncenin bir şeyler
yapabilmenin başı Hayret harekete
geçirici bir duygu ama bugün Artık
hiçbir Hayret etmiyoruz her şeyi sıradan
hemen Bilmem bir canlı kullanıyorsunuz
bir gazete köşesinde haber olup geçiyor
büyük bir akademik başarı büyük bir
sanat eseri büyük bir Hadise artık o
kadar ilginizi çekmiyor malumat
içerisinde şaşırmaz hale gelmiş
abone ol
13. özelliğimiz özfarkındalık yeni
uyanınca Suriye sana Öz farkındalığı
üzerine çalışmaya karar vermiş
insanlardan çıkacak Çünkü dünyayı
algılayan biz onu zihninde yaratan bizi
bu yarattığımız çevrenin Aslında
sorumlusu olduğumuzu fark ettiğimizde
gerçek tanımamız gereken kişinin
kendimiz olduğunu fark ediyoruz ve
kendimizi ne kadar zatlar açarsak
Aslında hayatımızda o kadar doğru yönde
düzenleyebileceğiniz ve verimli
yapabileceğimizi kaçınılmaz olarak fark
ediyoruz özfarkındalık Tan sonra benim
tabiata bakınca gördüm önemli bir şey
var almaktan önce vermek katkı vermek
biyolojik Dünya böyle Yaşar karşılıklı
ilişkilerle üç buçuk milyar yıldır bu
dünyada enteresan bir hikaye yazdı
canlılık bir zaman önce almaya çalıştık
hep özellikle Hani bu gözü doymaz yeni
sistemi nasıl pek Yeni sayılmaz artık
bayağı eskidi birkaç Yüzyıl oldu Hababam
alalım istiyoruz ama vermeye
başladığımız da işler çok değişmeye
o Muhtemelen onu sevgili şefimiz unutun
annesinden öğrenebiliriz ve sokaktaki O
işte eksiklik içerisindeki insana kafayı
takabilecek derecede katkı verme
güdüsünü kaybetmemiş insanların sayısını
artırmamız gerekiyor ve en önemli
şeylerden bir tanesi bir haber alıyoruz
titriyor Uz iyi bir şey oluyor aşırı
seviniriz iki dakika sonra o sevincimiz
uçuyor bir komut haberi ise iki dalga 3.
dalga dışarıdan başlıyor Çökük veriyoruz
duyduğumuz dışarıdan gelen her şeyi göre
değişiyor yeni dünyanın Cesur insanı
duygularının dizgini elinde tutabilen ve
duygusal istiklal ya da işte
psikolojideki adı veriliyor istediğimiz
becerisi üzerine aktif olarak çalışan
insanlardan çıkacak Çünkü duygusal
durumunuz bu kadar dalgalandığın da
hayata maalesef sadece seyirci kalıp
oradaki kötü hadiselerin geçmesini
beklemek içinde bir şey yapamıyoruz ki
duygusal Ben durabilmek L biraz
da bitirdim zihnimde Yani bu da mı Yani
bir dur bir reaktif olma şimdi kötü
hadiseler hep sürecekmiş gibi tepki
veriyoruz iyi şeyler Sonuçta kadar devam
edecekmiş gibi tepki veriyoruz Hani
bizim kötü tane diyorlar buda geçer yahu
Yani bir dur bir bak bakalım Yani bunun
gerçek durumun içeriğine neleri
kapsadığını bir görelim onu bir
kabullenirim ve önümüze bakalım tarzında
bir yaklaşıma vaktimiz yoksa bunun için
durmamız lazım bunun için bir nefes
deyip ne oluyor diye bir bakmamız lazım
altıncı özelliğin dünyanın Cesur insanın
bu kalabalık bu tantana içerisinde
seçebilmek öğrenmemiz lazım özellikle
çocuklarımıza seçebilmesi öğretmemiz
lazım yönümüzü bulamama sebebimiz
bunların içinden Neyi yapacağımızı
bilemiyoruz birçok yaratıcı beyinler ve
Doğan çocuğumuz Etraftaki o kadar fazla
yaratıcı uyarana maruz kalıyorlar ki hiç
yapamıyorlar elleri ayakları
düğümleniyor dolayısıyla biraz önce
sevgili öğretmenimiz Caner'e
ne anlattı gibi onlara bir seçme yolu
göstermemiz örnek değil oluşturmamız
gerekiyor Bu geçtik Evet bir sonraki
benim en önemli buldum bir gelin temeli
bilmiyorum demeyi hayatımıza
yerleştireceğiz Bence bizim temel
sorunumuz her şeyi biliyoruz Evet her
şeyi biliyoruz siyasetle ilgili
kararlarımızı kesip inançlarımızı
kesinlik çok iyi gözden geçirdik
dünyadaki bütün aşağı indirip kendimi
seçtik falan filan eşimizin çok uzun
arkadaşımızın ne olduğunu çok iyi
biliyoruz dünyanın nereye gittiğini çok
farkındayız Bu onların hepsi Ben
kompresör Bunlar çok emin olabiliyoruz
bu Emin Niye artık bırakıp bilmiyorum
deyip öğrenmenin kapılarını açmak ve
hiçbir şey bilmediğimi zi fark etmek
lazım ve benim her önemsediğim son madde
K Usta dans edebilmeyi öğrenmemiz
gerekiyor Eka Usta dans İsterdim ki 1020
dakikam daha olsun bunu Ayrıca anlatayım
Ama daha önce çok anlattım internette
Benim adım yan
bu hızda çok şey bulabilirsiniz kaosta
dans etmek hayatı anlamak hayatta dans
etmek anlamına geliyor Sabah Mesela bir
dansımızı izledik burada Buyurun diktim
yani bir şeyler oluyor da bizde Hatta
yapmak istedikleri çıksak da biz de hani
o müziği öyle uyabilecek diye bu kadar
Usta olmamıza gerek yok Hayatın bir ismi
müziği var Onu duyabildiğimiz zaman Kaos
dediğimiz meselenin ne olduğunu
anlayacağız Kaos karışıklık Anarşi
düzensizlik anlamında kullandığımız
biterim amma velakin Ben bilimsel olarak
şunu net söyleyebilirim ki Kaos
dediğimiz şey Aslı tabiatın işletim
sistemi bizim düzen algınız yalan
tabiatın ne zaman ne yapacağı pek belli
olmayan Ama belli bir düzen içerisinde
devam etmeyi sürdüren o muhteşem düzeni
bizim esas duymamız gereken müzik Çünkü
biz onun içinde yetiştik son birkaç
yüzyıldır Makine gibi bir medeniyetin
içinde yolumuzu bulmaya gayret ediyoruz
Bu kaosu sadece ve sadece durduğumuzda
kendi Hayat etmemiz ve kendimize
baktığımızda çok iyi fark edebileceğiz
diye düşünüyorum Bu dans mesajı benim
için önemli hayatta yapamadığım bir şey
bu arada belki gözüküyor dur yani sistem
çok uygun değil böyle yapılmamış ı
mamadan sadece bedenen belli bir resmi
koymak değil Hayatın gelen koşulları
arasında sakince kabullenerek onunla kol
kola girerek ve hayatı kabul edip ondan
razı olarak yaşamak dediğimiz bir mantar
dayanıyor bulmuyorum dansları geçeriz
biraz daha iyi anlamak anlatacağım
Anlatacağım şimdi küçük baktım var mı
Bir Minik müzikal örnek vereyim size
şimdi orada bir gitarım var bir tane onu
bir alayım Şimdi verdim Ben yapacağım
sen sonucu sinir bilimci ne işi var
üniversiteden biri benim Hayran Olduğum
bir enstrüman o zaman aldım biraz müziği
denedim
bu yüzükle kendimi anlatmaya çalıştım
ama tembel birisi olduğum için şu çenede
Ustalaştık kadar Bunlar ulaşamadım sözüm
ki ben konuşarak anlatayım müziği
başkaları yapsın ama müziği hala
bırakamadım Yani evinde hala gitarların
kayıt sistemlerin falan var niye bu
kadar ben bu işle uğraşıyorum yani müzik
albümü yapmayacaksan ben niye bu Alette
sürekli oynuyorum diye düşünürken Burası
bir örnek vermek istedim şimdi bu altı
tane telden oluşan Ben sunan dünyanın en
yaygın Müslümanlardan bir herhalde
Normalde tekme vurduğunuzda bir ses
çıkaran bir alet bu Bu altı ter farklı
sesler çıkarıyor buradan duyuyorsunuz ve
bunların perde dediğimiz aralıklarına
parmağımızı bastığımızda da gibi sesler
çıkarabiliyoruz şimdi bu seslerin ne
olduğunu Muhtemelen çoğunuz
bilmiyorsunuz Mesela ben de sorsanız şu
adı ne Bu notanın bilmiyorum ama bu
o Başka not ayda bir araya gelince hemen
hemen dünyadaki bütün insanlar bunun
uyumlumu Uyumsuz mı olduğunu
söyleyebiliyor Mesela bir abi yani çok
müzikal değil gibi Ama şöyle bir şey
vereceğim size ya bir güzele benziyor
sanki biraz daha akordun biraz daha
yoksa daha iyi olabilirdi Ama her
birinde altı tane nota vuruyorum ve bu
notalar ne olduğunu çoğumuzun bilmediği
bir dizi içinde diziliyor ve bir şekilde
Beynimiz alıyor bunları birleştirip işi
yapıyor Ben şimdi da yapabilirim ya da
bu dili daha önce biraz öğrendiysem
[Müzik]
Ne gibi bir şeyler yapabilirim Bir de
işin Hani bu şu bile üretim olarak yatar
ritim bölümü var ve ritim bize bazı
şeyler anlatıyor Mesela şöyle bir ritim
yapsam bakın böyle burada 35 kafa
sallamaya başladı hemen bir şekilde bir
girmek istiyoruz Çünkü Bey indiğimizde
bir şey var resim duyunca bir coşuyor ve
Yani bu ritimlerde farklı farklı
duyguları ifade etmek için karşıdaki
İnsanların bu notaları ne olduğunu
bilmesi hiç gerekmiyor mesela neşeli bir
şey söylemek istiyorsan size ya o
bu mesela peki bu örneği niye vardım
birincisi notaları bilmenize gerek yok
müzikten anlamanıza gerek yok benim gibi
amatör Biraz acemiyim gitarist olsanız
Buradan işe yarar bir şeyler çıkara
biliyorsunuz anlamak için buradan hiçbir
bilmenize gerek yok ama daha da önemlisi
Ben bir akademisyen olarak 98 yılda en
son konserve çıktım ve Müzik işini
bıraktım bugün burada hazır tetikte
çıkmışken benim galiba yedincioda 88
konuşmam Daha önce hiç gitar çalma
Mıştım bu yeni dünyanın Resul insanı
hamlesi de benim cebimde olsun diye
burada Efendim bunu da kötü emellerine
alet etmiş oldum hepinize tavsiye
ediyorum fırsatı buldum yapmak Ben
Sağdaki saç aldım Allah'tan Kalabalık
diyor çok rezil olmadı kim Arkadaşlar
iyi dünyanın Cesur insanın ilk modelini
Böylece size teşekkür ediyorum ya